in this video we'll be talking about
Edward syndrome Edward syndrome is a
genetic condition in which the infants
have one extra copy of chromosome 18.
and this extra copy of chromosome 18
caused a lot of problems this Edward
syndrome is also known as Trisomy 18.
these babies has decreased muscle tone
problems in Heart and Lung overlapping
fingers low set ears clubbed feet and
many other problems in order to
understand all the phenotypes associated
with Edward syndrome you can use the
mnemonic known as Mr Edward where m
stands for microagnathia so low Jaws or
a narrow Jaws then renal abnormalities e
for 18th chromosome Trisomy D4 digits
which are overlapped then W stands for
nothing but a for abnormal intellect are
for rocker bottom feet and D for
diseased heart
so these babies doesn't survive long
because they have profound heart defects
so let us look at what heart defects do
they have first of all there is ductus
arteriosus
there is a ventral septal defect there
are polyvalvular defects
including thick leaflets long coordinate
knee and hypoplastic papillary muscles
all of these lead to a problem in the
circulatory system and decrease the
heart health that's why they don't
survive for long
anyway another distinct feature of these
Edward syndrome children is they have
overlapped disease and under developed
thumb so these are kind of like Hallmark
signs of Edward syndrome so let's talk
about the biology behind Edward syndrome
so in Edward syndrome there is a extra
chromosome 18 but why is so so this is a
normal process of meiotic division due
to mutic division four types of gametes
are formed each of these gametes are
haploid so they have one copy of a
chromosome coming from the
mother or father
in the process of non-disjunction the
segregation is not equal one particular
gamut might get n plus one chromosome
and imagine this particular chromosome
which is n plus one is basically the
18th chromosome
so when there is a fertilization the
sperm has let's say chromosome 18 1 copy
ideally the ovum would also have one
copy and after the fertilization the
zygote would have two copies of
chromosome 18.
but
due to non-disjunction already the
mother's ovum has two copies of
chromosome 18 and the other copy comes
from the father so end result is there
are three chromosome 18 and that's the
sole biological reason behind Edward
syndrome now there are different types
of Edward syndrome known as complete
Trisomy 18 which is very common in 93
percent of Edward syndrome cases are
complete Trisomy that means every cell
in the body has three copies of
chromosome 18. the extra crop copy of
chromosome obviously came due to
non-disjunction defects
now there are also other situations
known as partial Trisomy 18 where the
third copy doesn't contain the entire
chromosome but it has the segment of
chromosome 18 maybe 18 Q let's say
then there is Mosaic Trisomy 18 which is
very rare but in Mosaic Trisomy some of
the cells of the body has normal
chromosome 18 that means two pairs of
chromosome 18 but some of the cells has
three pairs of chromosome 18. so the
entire uh baby is kind of like a mosaic
and the phenotype is also highly
variable ranges from normal to the
severe phenotypes
so
question is how common is Edward's
syndrome every one case out of 5000 to
6000 life birth is Edward syndrome so
it's not really uncommon actually it's
the second most common genetic defects
in babies
so what increases the risk of Edward
syndrome maternal age because maternal
age increase the risk of non-disjunction
in the meiosis II so that is why
maternal age matters
now the symptoms of Edward syndrome can
be detected during pregnancy so there
could be very low fetal activity small
placenta a single artery in the
umbilical cord all of these things would
be a indicative of Edward syndrome but
anyway the detailed test would be done
by amniocentesis or chorionic villi
sampling
so amniocentesis is a process where
which a needle is used to withdraw some
amount of amniotic fluid from the fetus
and chorionic wheelie sampling is a
process by which some amount of fetal
chorion is taken away and all these
cells are cultured in a dish eventually
the karyotyping experiment is performed
if there is Trisomy 18 there would be
three pairs of 18th chromosome in this
karyotype so this is how the
confirmatory test of Edward syndrome is
done but anyway amniocentesis or
chorionic Wheely sampling always is
associated with the risk of miscarriage
anyway there is no treatment for Edward
syndrome so far most of the babies which
has Edward syndrome die before or
shortly after they are born
and a small number of Edward syndrome
babies are alive but they hardly make it
to their first birthday
some of the Mosaic cause of Edward
syndrome which are very rare they
survive but even they don't survive till
adolescence
so this kind of syndrome doesn't have
any treatment in future who knows with
help of crispr cas9 there would be
editing and it is possible to treat or
improve the lifestyle of these babies
anyway this is The quick summary of
Edward syndrome you can get the notes
and flashcards in my Facebook page or
Instagram
you can support our Channel using paytm
PayPal or UPI
and follow us in social media see you in
next video